bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir quel bilan de la Coop
27 la Conférence mondiale sur le climat
s'achève demain en Égypte les pays du
Sud première victime du réchauffement
dénonce tous un manque de volonté
politique alors à quoi servent ces
grands symposium pourquoi maintenir
l'objectif des 1,5 degrés s'il est déjà
hors d'atteinte comme le disent les
scientifiques de pas alimenter aussi la
fameuse écho anxiété qui touche une
partie de la jeunesse on en parle dans
un instant dans notre grand débat avec
nos invités notre grand témoin ce soir
est un de nos grands magistrats
financiers il a passé 20 ans à explorer
les circuits opaque des paradis fiscaux
son dernier livre est une petite bombe
sur la duplicité des Occidentaux
aménager le secret et bancaire pour
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale il veut
tout changer renovan rumbeck est avec
Louane ce soir enfin trois affranchis
trois parties pris le coup de gueule de
Bertrand Perrier après le refus
capitaine des Bleus Hugo Lloris de
porter un brassard arc-en-ciel au Qatar
pays où l'homosexualité est criminalisée
cohéridel va s'interroger sur le retour
possible des gilets jaunes après la fin
de la ristourne à la pompe et puis le
Palais Bourbon express de Marco pommier
ce soir premier feu vert des députés une
inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution voilà pour le menu ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
la confiance s'effrite entre le Nord et
le Sud à alerté Emmanuel Macron à
Charmel Cheikh les mots du Secrétaire
général de l'ONU en ouverture de la
cop27 vont beaucoup plus loin l'humanité
a le choix coopérer ou périr il s'agisse
soit d'impact de solidarité climatique
soit d'impact de suicide collectif on va
s'interroger ce soir sur les résultats
de cette nouvelle conférence mondiale
pour le climat qui s'achève demain
bonsoir Antoine Armand et bienvenue sur
ce plateau ravi de vous retrouver vous
êtes député Renaissance le parti
présidentiel député de Haute-Savoie
membre de la commission Développement
Durable bonsoir Sandrine Rousseau
bonsoir bienvenue à nouveau sur ce
plateau député Europe Écologie Les Verts
de Paris bonsoir Antoine bueno ravi de
vous accueillir vous êtes essayiste
conseiller au Sénat et vous venez de
publier l'effondrement Nora
l'effondrement du monde Nora
probablement c'est écrit en tout petit
palieux c'est aux éditions Flammarion il
y avait permis de procréer aussi en 2019
chez Alban qui va résonner avec
l'actualité avec avec évidemment cette
population mondiale qui vient de
dépasser les 8 milliards d'êtres humains
on en parlera enfin Rémi lovery
consultant à la Fondation Jean Jaurès
qui vient décrire avec deux côtes cette
étude passionnante intitulée dans la
tête des échos anxieux il nous rejoint
dans quelques petites minutes mais
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir de
cette COP va-t-elle rester dans
l'histoire les pays d'Afrique ont-ils
raison d'être fâchées si j'ai bien
compris lakowski pour ouvrir le bal
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors bah si j'ai bien compris
Myriam vous avez décidé de consacrer
cette émission à la cop27 bon je dis pas
que c'est pas un sujet important sauver
le monde sauver l'humanité mais vous
parliez de déco anxiété je me demande si
c'est pas un sujet la cop27 qui va un
peu déprimer notre téléspectateurs
[Musique]
vous connaissez j'imagine tous Pascal
Campin vraiment un cas brillant un
président de la commission environnement
au Parlement européen et bien en 2012 il
venait de chez les Verts il est rentré
au gouvernement de François Hollande et
il disait alors là pas le droit de
déprimer vous voyez ce qui a bien un
sujet sur lequel on n'a pas le droit
d'être pessimiste c'est le climat bon
dix ans plus tard il en est un peu
revenu et l'idée maintenant c'est qu'une
interdit plus d'être pessimiste c'était
la semaine dernière sur France Inter
question simple pour commencer est-ce
que les cops servent encore à quelque
chose Pascal Campin je vais pas que vous
cacher que je suis particulièrement
pessimiste sur celle-là il y a 10 ans
la dernière fois qu'on a parlé de succès
pour une COP souvenez-vous c'était il y
a 7 ans
2015 à Paris sous la présidence de
Laurent Fabius qu'on embrasse évidemment
ancien président de l'Assemblée et moi
il y a les 186 pays c'était mis d'accord
pour limiter à un degré 5 la hausse des
températures donc le monde parlait d'un
succès en disant succès à confirmé
évidemment et donc sept ans plus tard le
succès confirmé ou pas
vous croyez que le gérer c'est à dire
les 20 pays les plus riches du monde
ceux qui émettent 80% des gaz à effet de
serre ne serait pas capable de tenir
leurs paroles enfin non c'est pas
sérieux regardez dans la presse bien sûr
que l'objectif est maintenu le G20 a red
c'était un rhum mais ils l'ont redit
hier l'objectif est toujours limité un
degré 5 donc il est atteignable cet
objectif alors non attention ça c'est du
langage diplomatique on a dit il faut
réaffirmer notre ambition donc
réaffirmer dans ton buisson on dit ça
quand on n'a pas vraiment l'intention de
le faire on veut juste réaffirmer son
ambition non mais regardez comment ça se
passe
le G20 c'est les échos qui nous le
disent vont beaucoup trop lentement pour
réduire leurs émissions ils devraient
aller 10 fois plus vite le résultat
c'est que l'objectif 1,5 tout le monde
le dit enfin les scientifiques en tout
cas paraît hors d'atteinte et maintenant
on est plutôt sur un autre
2,5°c
je vous donne un exemple c'était il y a
un an à la COP 26 donc à Glasgow donc
tout n'avait pas été super mais il y
avait au moins un truc dans Boris
Johnson était fier de pouvoir se
féliciter on l'écoute
et du spion il ne fait aucun doute que
Glasgow a sonné le glas de l'énergie au
charbon c'est une fantastique réussite
et ce n'est qu'une parmi tant d'autres à
émerger de la cop26
voyez l'an dernier les Occidentaux
faisaient la leçon au pays on voit le
développement qui utilise encore pas mal
de charbon en leur disant les gars faut
absolument arrêter avec le charbon sauf
qu'un an plus tard qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il y a eu la guerre du prenne et
on a commencé à réouvrir des centrales
en charbon en France en Allemagne
évidemment en Occident c'est
impressionnant
d'acheter du charbon donc à l'Afrique du
Sud donc les exportations de l'Afrique
du Sud ont Togo ont été multipliées par
7 nous on se retrouve dans une situation
où on achète du charbon à l'Afrique du
Sud alors que l'an dernier on leur
disait qu'il fallait absolument arrêter
d'en produire donc quel effet ça produit
sur les autres pays d'après vous ça les
énerve les Africains pas très contents
mais même pas seulement les Africains
aussi les pays qui sont exposés aux
catastrophes climatiques donc c'est
vraiment une des grandes questions dans
cette cop27 est-ce que les pays les plus
riches ceux qui sont les principaux
responsables du réchauffement
ne doivent pas dédommager les pays les
plus pauvres qui eux sont les
principales victimes donc l'Europe a
prévu d'avancer un milliard mais c'est
une toute petite somme c'est des
centaines de milliards que réclament
plutôt les pays du Sud donc pendant
qu'on réfléchit je rappellerai que
d'autres jettent de l'huile sur le feu
donc regardez notre
célèbre Vladimir Poutine qui lui ne
cesse de souligner que voilà les
Occidentaux se comportent un peu comme
autant des colonies par rapport aux
Africains donc évidemment ça serait
peut-être de l'intérêt des pays riches
des Occidentaux de prouver au pays du
Sud aux Africains que on est prêt à être
vrai partenaire être collaborer enfin
moi je dis ça après ça vous débattre
merci billet Stéphane dacowski mordant
comme chaque soir Antoine Armand une COP
pour rien cette cop27 franchement
c'est pas notre rôle de responsable
politique de se contenter des déceptions
donc on a un sujet très simple qui est
coopéré ou périr on a les mots
brables pays de l'hémisphère sud
notamment qui n'ont pas atteint notre
niveau de développement et à qui on
vient dire aujourd'hui
écouter il faut faire la transition
c'est à vous de la faire et il faut que
chacun fasse des efforts c'est à la fois
injuste et irresponsable donc il faut
absolument que l'Union européenne et
l'ensemble des pays dit riche mettent
les moyens tout de suite il faut mais on
voit bien qu'on n'y est pas là donc à
qui la faute on a eu un été
catastrophique je crois qu'il y a une
vraie prise de conscience les
inondations monstres au Pakistan les
sécheresses voilà les feux les incendies
partout vraiment franchement les gens
qui regardent ces cops année après année
ne comprennent pas à quoi elles servent
c'est le principe de la diplomatie c'est
extraordinairement frustrant mais vous
n'avez pas d'autre solution que d'aller
convaincre les États-Unis la Chine
l'ensemble des pays émetteurs de carbone
on a vu la déclaration ignoble et
hypocrite de Vladimir Poutine nous
n'avons pas d'autres solutions après on
peut discuter du format est-ce que la
coop est le meilleur format est-ce qu'il
faut pas développer les sommets il y a
le One shunt il va y avoir un One forest
Summit est-ce qu'il faut pas cibler le
président Lula qui vient d'être élu à
annoncer qu'il allait stopper d'ici 2030
on en félicité là la déforestation en
Amazonie est-ce que c'est une question
de format comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
convaincre davantage nos partenaires ce
sont des questions qui se posent à nos
diplomates aux diplomates européens mais
en tout cas on ne peut pas se résoudre
est considérer que parce que c'est une
déception on va arrêter de convaincre
nos partenaires internationaux on va
regarder demain la déclaration finale
mais on voit que sur ce qui était la
thématique principale le financement la
solidarité pour les pays qui sont déjà
impactés par le réchauffement là on
n'est pas sur une adaptation on est sur
une réparation ça coince il y a les
Européens qui donnent de l'argent mais
c'est entre ça de ce qu'il faut à qui la
faute la Chine les États-Unis à qui la
faute
aujourd'hui si on regarde le stock
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère puisque je rappelle que à
chaque fois que vous émettez du carbone
il reste plusieurs années jusqu'à 100
ans dans l'atmosphère actif donc en fait
on est obligé de regarder l'histoire de
des émissions de carbone pour comprendre
quelle est la responsabilité dans la
situation actuelle forcément cette
constater que le continent africain dans
son ensemble dans son ensemble les
responsable que de 4% des émissions
alors même que ces populations sont les
plus exposées parmi les plus exposés au
monde au dérèglement climatique donc en
fait c'est un puissant justice
climatique mais c'est plus qu'une
injustice c'est un scandale en réalité
dire que l'Afrique qui n'a jamais accédé
à la richesse à la hauteur en tous les
cas de l'Europe ou des États-Unis
et la première exposée la première
stigmatisée parce que quand on parle de
dérèglement climatique souvent en plus
on pointe la population l'augmentation
de la population et ses continents
africains qui est encore pointé du doigt
alors même qu'ils ne sont responsables
de 4% est responsable et bien
maigreur des avancées la responsabilité
elle est chez nous elle est clairement
chez nous dire nous ne voulons pas
reconnaître ni notre responsabilité dans
l'histoire ni notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui a changé notre système de
consommation et de production et en fait
quand on arrive à la Coop 27 comme est
arrivé Emmanuel Macron complètement vide
les poches complètement vides de mesures
passées c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive et on
dit ah bah maintenant on va faire bah en
fait on a aucune espèce de crédibilité
en Europe il y a des millions donnés par
la France en particulier il y a des
millions enfin il faudrait les compter
en milliards déjà et puis par ailleurs
c'est quand on voit la l'espèce de
prudence qu'il y a voir la faiblesse
qu'il y a du gouvernement dès que se
présente une mesure qui pourrait être
une forme d'espoir dans la dans la
gestion de la crise climatique et
immédiatement il vote contre
immédiatement ils appellent à voter
contre on l'a vu sur la rénovation
thermique des logements c'est pas grand
chose on l'a vu sur le rail c'est pas
grand chose et pour pourtant à chaque
fois à chaque fois il y a une fin de mon
recevoir
tant que pays historique et en tant que
pays qui a été le pays des Droits
Humains de grandes innovations comme ça
social et de grandes avancées épopées et
bien on pourrait jouer ce rôle de Lead
et en fait on ne le fait pas parce qu'on
refuse nous-même de notre modèle elles
sont peu lisible pour les français pour
tous ceux qui s'intéressent au climat
c'est c'est grandes réunions est-ce que
ça sert quand même à quelque chose que
les chefs d'État de la planète qui parle
premièrement au moment où on se parle là
il est peut-être encore un tout petit
peu tôt c'est à dire que vous me
permettrez de conserver un peu d'espoir
vous savez c'est l'histoire de la boîte
de Pandore on a tout perdu mais il reste
un peu l'espoir et on sait qu'il y a une
dramaturgie dans ces grands raouts là et
que à la fin il sort quelque chose donc
moi je prends ma boule de cristal si
vous voulez on en parle sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà moi je vous parie que il y
aura quand même quelque chose demain
c'est à dire que ça sera pas rien
il y aura quelque chose et je suis
d'accord sans doute pas c'est une
évidence on va pas sortir un merveilleux
lapin du chapeau donc sans doute pas
quelque chose à la hauteur mais quelque
chose sur les cubes je dirais vous
connaissez l'expression c'est comme le
bac le bac ne vaut rien mais rien de
volbach et ben les cops c'est la même
chose c'est pas terrible mais pour
l'instant en terme de coopération
internationale on n'a rien inventé de
mieux et le peu c'est à dire on est
parti de rien il faut quand même le
rappeler le peu qui a eu c'est à
l'occasion de Coop on disait tout à
l'heure que depuis la COP 21 il s'est
rien passé c'est pas vrai à Glasgow il
s'est quand même passé quelque chose
c'est-à-dire que on a renforcé les
engagements des états on était sur une
trajectoire à plus de 3 degrés en 2100
et on est passé sur une trajectoire tout
ça étant très conditionné je vois
Sandrine Rousseau qui lève les yeux au
ciel et je suis d'accord c'est à dire
que tout dépend de des d'être capable
d'atteindre les objectifs qu'on se fixes
de la COP 27 la conclusion on verra
d'accord final mais il y a un engagement
qui est réaffirmé dès 1,5 degrés il y a
énormément scientifique de Gier qui nous
disent que c'est en vacances
pour une raison très simple on nous dit
que les températures ont déjà augmenté
de 1,1 degré en réalité c'est plus 1,2
ou 1,3 parce que il y a un certain
nombre d'aérosols qui sont injectés dans
l'atmosphère et qui réduisent l'effet du
réchauffement c'est à dire que si on
nettoie l'atmosphère par exemple de la
de la dessus de la suie du charbon et
bien les températures reviennent au
niveau auquel devrait être c'est-à-dire
1,2 ou 1,3 de plus par rapport à l'air
industriel donc par effet de latence
même si pas un coup de baguette magique
du jour au lendemain on arrête d'émettre
des des gaz à effet de serre de toute
façon on y arrive au 1,5 et même au-delà
on sait même il faut être réaliste je
travaille là-dessus que les deux degrés
c'est extrêmement difficilement tenable
voir ça n'est pas tenable et que c'est
autour de 2060 2070 qu'on en sera là à
partir de ce moment là c'est hyper grave
pourquoi parce que ça met en branle des
mécanismes de rétroaction positive c'est
à dire tout simplement la nature qui se
met d'elle-même indépendamment de nous à
émettre des gaz à effet de serre et là
le phénomène devient totalement
incontrôlable et on va vers des
températures de l'Amazonie par exemple
exactement on va parler justement de la
manière dont sont reçus ces nouvelles
bonsoir Rémi lovelier merci d'être là je
le disais vous avez réalisé une enquête
qualitative avec de co-auteur Marie
caillot et Théo Verdier pour la
Fondation Jean Jaurès on va rentrer dans
le détail dans un instant mais les
jeunes que vous avez interrogé juste
pour comprendre ils suivent c'est
grandes réunions ça les intéresse où il
y a tellement tellement d'actualités
autour du climat que c'est pas forcément
ça qui va les déterminer s'il y a des
résultats ou pas ces énormes conférences
mondiales ces jeunes ils sont déjà très
informés donc ils ont parfaitement
connaissance de la COP elle est très
visible même si elle est pas trop
lisible effectivement par contre ils en
attendent pas grand chose clairement
promesses ils ont eu déjà plein il y en
a beaucoup qui ont été formulées par les
responsables politiques et ce qui nous
dit c'est que justement c'est les
personnes qui ont le pouvoir qui sont
responsables de l'action face aux
changements climatiques et pour
l'instant il ne voit pas suffisamment
d'actions pour que ça répondent alors ma
lettre qu'il ressentent au quotidien
vis-à-vis de ces changements dans le
détail Antoine Armand pour terminer sur
sur ce chapitre de la COP quand même on
a vu aux différentes tribunes tous ces
chefs d'États qui sont impactés je pense
au Pakistan je pense à tous les États
insulaires Sainte Lucie c'était terrible
vraiment au final justice climatique au
rendez-vous ou pas c'est le combat du
président de la République et si Madame
Rousseau n'était pas obsédée par une
haine anti-emmanuel Macron elle
consacrer non mais elle constaterait
elle constaterait que le pays qui montre
l'exemple dans les instances
internationales c'est la France alors
j'ai signé une conférence
de l'exploitation dans les fonds marins
le président de la République a porté ça
à l'agenda on a signé je crois vous
aussi madame Rousseau une demande que la
France qui a ce qui est sorti du triple
du traité sur la charte de l'énergie
permette à l'Europe de sortir c'est par
les efforts mondiaux qu'on arrive et
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui a porté
l'augmentation sur le fond de l'action
pour le climat et qui demande que
l'objectif des 100 milliards des pertes
est dommages qu'on évoquait soit atteint
et qui va convaincre ses homologues
est-ce qu'on y est arrivé à ce stade il
est trop tôt pour le dire visiblement on
y arrivera pas tout à fait mais notre
rôle de responsable politique c'est de
continuer avec la France dans un dans un
patriotisme mondial et citoyen
éco-citoyens d'y arriver alors je vous
propose qu'on écoute quelques jeunes à
présent et vous vous nous direz Rémi
lovery est-ce que vous avez tiré comme
enseignement de cette enquête évidemment
on comprend bien que que tout cela ça
alimente une certaine écho anxiété c'est
un concept d'une chercheuse en santé
publique belge si je dis pas de bêtises
qu'il avait théorisé en 1997 vous nous
direz ce qu'elle ce que ça recouvre
comme réalité de quoi parle-t-on avant
de vous entendre on va faire le point
avec Diane karcher
incendie dévastateur
sécheresse historique fonte des glaces
spectaculaires autant de motifs déco
anxiété pour de nombreux jeunes une
angoisse liée au dérèglement climatique
alors comment s'exprime ce mal-être au
quotidien pour le savoir la Fondation
Jean Jaurès a rencontré 34 écho anxieux
entre 18 et 30 ans selon cette étude
trois sentiments dominent chez eux la
colère la peur et l'angoisse devant la
Sorbonne nous avons demandé à des
étudiants de nous expliquer leur
ressenti il y a d'abord la colère envers
les dirigeants qui selon eux ne prennent
pas la mesure des enjeux d'avoir
conscience à l'échelle on va dire
citoyenne qu'on doit faire quelque chose
et que les c'est pas la priorité des
je sais pas des politiques quoi vient
ensuite la peur des conséquences du
changement climatique
la peur elle est plutôt orientée vers le
futur j'irai parce que c'est le père
d'anticipation
on a peur du monde de dystopique qui se
profile devant nous c'est ça qui peut
faire peur en fait de savoir que ça va
probablement très probablement mal se
passer pour nous
angoisse enfin face à leur choix de vie
mise en balance avec l'avenir de la
planète des moments un peu de blues on
se dit bon bah quoi bon encore se lever
si au final dans quelques années il y
aura plus rien c'est un peu ça de moment
un peu de ouais de perte de morale
face au constat certains choisissent
l'engagement militant mais pour beaucoup
c'est dans les choix de vie personnelle
que ce reflète leur écho anxiété comme
le fait de ne pas avoir d'enfant
peut-être que toi tu vas un enfant mais
est-ce que l'enfant sera réellement
heureux et aura réellement ce qu'il veut
plus tard et vivre dans un monde entre
guillemets qui sera adapté à lui donc
c'est d'abord par là que je suis passé
et forcément du coup ça touchait à
l'écologie et et en passant par là on se
rend compte que de toute façon faire un
enfant écologiquement c'est une
catastrophe d'autres se battent sur le
terrain de l'alimentation de venir rien
vegan ou simplement manger moins de
viande pour réduire leur empreinte
carbone
alors Rémi lovery on va aller dans le
détail à présent comment vous avez
procédé une trentaine de jeunes que vous
avez interrogé longuement qui était déjà
préoccupé par la question climatique
c'est ça c'est ça exactement c'est
concentré sur des jeunes qui exprimaient
un fort degré de préoccupation alors
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit qu'est-ce qui
les angoisse le plus c'est de ne pas
avoir une place dans dans à l'avenir
dans une société voilà qui le désire
différente est-ce que leurs rêves les
ont abandonnés qu'est-ce qu'il est on
sent qu'ils sont en colère mais mais
quelle est leur angoisse la source de
leur angoisse c'est l'état du monde
c'est c'est ce qui voit à la télé sur
les réseaux sociaux ce qui lisent dans
les rapports du GIEC
après et c'est ce qu'il voit autour
d'eux aussi il y en a beaucoup par
exemple qui habitent dans des sur le
bord de mer qui voit la plage réduire
tous les ans donc ça renvoie à des
sentiments de déco anxiété
après ce qui les rend en colère
justement c'est l'inaction qui constate
parce que ils ont bien conscience qu'ils
ont une responsabilité en tant que
citoyen il la remet jamais en question
mais par contre il voit que la grande
part des actions à mener se font au
niveau collectif et que ces actions ne
viennent pas où sont trop timoré ils ont
l'impression que leur avenir est bouchée
est-ce qu'ils ont l'impression que
leur choix seront forcément contraints
ça a été très bien exprimé par la jeune
fille dans le reportage effectivement
par moment il se demande à quoi bon
continuer dans un futur où il se disent
que par exemple tel métier qui voudrait
exercer n'existera plus en fait du fait
du changement climatique où il se
demande effectivement à quoi bon avoir
des enfants si c'est pour juste émettre
plus de carbone
vous en connaissez des jeunes anxieux de
l'avenir à cause du climat
énormément et je pense que beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes d'ailleurs il y avait
une étude qui était sortie de ça
quelques mois qui disait que 45% des
jeunes étaient con anxieux donc c'est
énorme mais c'est normal parce que c'est
leur avenir et on a différents
de très grands écho anxieux racontez-moi
ça et je pense qu'il traduit comment par
exemple sur la question des enfants je
pense que tout s'il se pose la question
de savoir s'ils auront des enfants tous
sont devenus végétariens et vegan enfin
vraiment il y a quelque chose de l'ordre
d'un rejet de tout ce qui peut polluer
de manière massive et presque tripale et
il y a aussi une colère qui monte et ça
je pense qu'on ne mesure pas la colère
qui est en train de monter dans la
population particulièrement chez les
jeunes parce qu'ils estiment à tort ou à
raison mais moi je pense qu'ils ont
raison que finalement on est plus
accroché à un niveau de vie à un mode de
vie qu'elle leur avenir et quand on leur
pose la question comme ça et quand ils
voient à quel point on a des difficultés
à prendre à moindre mesure pour vous
cette coxiété c'est plus un levier pour
agir faut pas l'apaiser forcément ah non
moi je pense qu'il faut pas l'apaiser je
pense je pense par contre il faut lui
donner un débouché politique
c'est-à-dire que l'écho anxiété doit se
transformer parce que pardon je termine
juste là dessus pour dire que je pense
que le problème face auquel on est
actuellement c'est que l'écologie est
perçue comme une forme de contrainte
individuelle sur nos comportements alors
qu'il faudrait que ça soit une espèce
d'épopée collective à laquelle on est
fier de participer et eux ils sont prêts
à cela mais nous nous ne sommes pas
prêts encore à participer à cette époque
et c'est cela qu'il nous faut construire
politiquement Antoine c'est d'accord on
prend tous là des mines très graves mais
les co-anxiété c'est une super nouvelle
quand même ça prouve qu'il y a une prise
de conscience quelqu'un qui n'est pas
éco anxieux c'est potentiellement
quelqu'un qui est écho indifférent ou
écho désinformer ça serait encore plus
inquiétant de ne pas éprouver cette
anxiété parce que cette anxiété elle est
liée à la conscience qu'il y a un
problème et que c'est un problème très
grave et que ce problème là risque fort
de transformer radicalement le monde et
dans votre lit vous êtes très dur avec
tous les collapsologues les effondristes
ceux qui présentent le monde de façon
parfois tellement qui a pas d'espoir
possible pas de chemin alors c'est un
petit peu plus nuancé que ça moi je dis
que l'effondrement est possible mais pas
inéluctable donc j'essaye d'avoir un
discours mesuré mais en fonction de
donner extrêmement précises en fonction
de rapport en fonction d'études en
fonction des chiffres etc donc vis-à-vis
des collapsologues je leur dis juste ne
fermez pas l'horizon des possibles on
peut encore s'en sortir il y a un panel
de solutions qui peuvent être encore mis
en oeuvre mais et Sandrine Rousseau
quand elle parle de mouvement collectif
c'est que elle exprime un espoir qu'on
puisse éviter le pire j'imagine
c'était réjouissant les co anxiété chez
les jeunes j'ai 31 ans je suis juste
au-dessus du panel mais j'ai 31 ans et
bien sûr comme comme mes co
générationnels et puis les plus âgés
aussi je suis extrêmement inquiet c'est
d'ailleurs un des moteurs de mon
engagement politique et je souscris à ce
qui vient d'être dit la question c'est
comment on arrive à transcrire ça en
action puisqu'une une anxiété qui reste
une anxiété
c'est pas forcément quelque chose de la
colère qui n'aboutit pas à des résultats
notre responsabilité en tant qu'élu
c'est d'arriver à des résultats et donc
de ne pas tomber ni dans l'inaction et
l'indifférence c'est évidemment le pire
ni dans l'agitation stérile l'agitation
qui ne conduit pas
avancer sur les solutions
sur le diagnostic bonsoir leur nous là
et merci d'être avec nous à distance
d'être journaliste et autrice de ce
livre qui a déjà fait couler beaucoup
dans comment rester écolo sans finir
dépressif c'était aux éditions Tana
alors quelle solution vous-même vous
êtes traversé par cette anxiété ou pas
oui oui mais je pense que c'est pas
réservé aux jeunes et si les vieux enfin
c'est les adultes qui sont aux manettes
avaient été un peu plus écho anxieux on
en serait peut-être pas tout à fait là
oui il traversait de toute façon on n'en
sort pas et comme disait Antoine bueno
c'est un signe je pense de très très
bonne santé mentale plutôt qu'elle est
bien dans un monde comme celui qui est
là actuellement qui se déploie devant
nous c'est plutôt ça le truc qui va pas
bien
quelles sont les solutions d'abord vivre
avec et accepter que que certainement
demain sera pire qu'aujourd'hui même si
c'est pas totalement foutu comme le dit
Antoine bueno mais les choses se
dégradent à une rapidité et une
intensité folle et en deux ans
d'ailleurs on a bien vu que le monde
avait un peu dévissé quoi les certitudes
d'hier ne sont plus là et
voilà on voit maintenant les effets
n'ont pas que des changements
climatiques
pardon ne pas faire d'enfants comme
certains jeunes le souhaitent fait
partie du panel de solutions ou pas
faire d'enfant c'est pas du tout la
question la solution pour lutter contre
l'écho anxiété et rien de mieux que
l'action que disait que l'action porte
en elle la magie la grâce et le pouvoir
et tous les jeunes dont vous parlez ils
sont déjà dans une forme d'action
attention à faire en sorte qu'il ne
tombe pas dans une forme de colère de
radicalité qui fera qu'ils iront faire
autre chose que que faire gicler des
soupes sur des tableaux vitrés voilà on
est plutôt à la croisée des chemins donc
en ce moment on a une société totalement
dissonante des politiques publiques
totalement dissonantes par rapport aux
intentions et voilà il y a cette
impuissance vous parliez de colère de
peur d'angoisse mais cette sensation
d'impuissance est plus forte que tout
donc quand on sent impuissant on reprend
le pouvoir sur sa vie et on essaye
d'agir dans son périmètre il s'a fait un
moment je pense aussi que beaucoup de
jeunes et de moins jeunes donc je fais
partie on agit localement dans les
territoires on essaye de relocaliser
l'économie nos consommations on essaye
de vivre avec moins pour plus de liens
mais moins de bien et
regardez tous ceux qui sont mis dans des
systèmes d'autonomie énergétique ou
alimentaire aujourd'hui n'ont pas les
problèmes que la majorité des personnes
qui ont pas pu le faire ont c'est-à-dire
face à une flambée des prix que ce soit
en termes de déplacement en termes de
chauffage etc merci beaucoup leurs noix
là on entend voilà une action à
l'échelle individuelle elle peut pas
évidemment se passer de l'action
collective cette question de la sobriété
démographique elle est quand même posée
elle est dans le débat aujourd'hui vous
vous la rejetez tous il y a cette
tribune dans Le Monde
réduire la population contribuerait à
l'atténuation du réchauffement
climatique c'est clair ce que moi
j'avais pointé c'est de dire attention
c'est pas le continent africain qui est
responsable de nos problèmes donc juste
poser ça quand même parce que il y a
quand même une petite tentation là de
dire on s'est enrichi on a pollué et en
plus on va accuser les autres donc on va
quand même calmer ce cette envie là et
puis la deuxième chose c'est que les
jeunes qui refusent de faire des enfants
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas un souhait
c'est-à-dire c'est l'inquiétude qui se
transmis d'un sacrifice ça dit à quel
point ils sont angoissés c'est ça qu'il
faut mesurer
si vos enfants vous vous le disent ça je
suis tellement angoissée que je ne veux
pas faire d'enfant qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez et je discute avec eux mais
je vais pas leur dire que le monde va
aller bien là on est il faut bien quand
même se rendre compte que cet été a été
un été de canicule de sécheresse
d'incendie qui a eu des villages entiers
plusieurs centres enfin au-dessus de 100
villages qui ont été abreuvés d'eau
potable par des camions-citernes et là
on est que à 1,1 là on est que 1,1 degré
on dit que quand pourquoi on posait 1,5
degrés comme une espèce de limite
au-delà de laquelle il était dangereux
d'aller parce que au-delà de 1,5 on il y
a des points de bascule et c'est boucles
de rétroaction qu'on ne maîtrise pas si
le golf stream s'arrête si l'Amazonie
devient une savane si il y a plus de
corail dans et s'il y a plus de corail
dans l'océan alors il y a des effets de
bascule dont on ne mesure pas les effets
donc en fait là on est à ce moment-là et
notre responsabilité à nous et de
prendre les mesures à la hauteur du défi
et là où on est faible c'est que on y
arrive pas et on a l'impression d'un
psychodrame à chaque fois qu'on présente
quelque chose se priver de viande et
d'un barbecue moi j'ai l'impression que
la France entière se était tout à coup
en position latérale de sécurité alors
qu'en fait il s'agit juste de diminuer
de 80 % les pays les plus frappés par le
réchauffement climatique sont aussi ceux
qui font le plus d'enfants
qu'est-ce qu'on dira demain s'il fera
pas notre porte la question de la
démographie c'est à la fois une question
de d'atténuation et d'adaptation
d'atténuation ça veut dire que c'est
évident et c'est pour ça que on doit
montrer des évidences maintenant dans le
le public un enfant de 7 ans comprend
que plus on est nombreux plus on a de
besoins plus on exerce de pression sur
les ressources planétaires ça allait
vers des politiques collectives de
malthusianisme moi je le souhaite mais
je ne pense pas qu'on le fasse parce que
c'est devenu un énorme tabou alors ça va
dans tous les sens là mais puisque vous
parlez de ce de politique
le Honor et au sud ce sont des
politiques très différentes au nord on
va pas toucher à la démographie du Nord
parce qu'elle est déjà extrêmement
faible mais on peut arrêter avec les
politiques nataliste qui sont assez peu
efficaces qui coûtent énormément et qui
permettraient de dégager des
financements pour mener au sud des
politiques de planning familial et
d'accès à l'éducation des filles c'est à
dire droit des femmes droits de la
nature même combat améliorer la
condition des femmes faire baisser c'est
de l'économie mais ça moi j'adhère
j'adhère à 100% juste un point très
important c'est aussi une question
d'adaptation la baisse de la de la de la
démographie parce que les pays qui vont
être en première ligne du réchauffement
climatique par exemple les pays
africains qui va concerner 3,5 milliards
de personnes moins il y aura de gens
dans ces zones là la bande équatoriale
en 2050 en 2100 évidemment moins la
catastrophe humanitaire sera importante
donc c'est les deux la question
démographique c'est l'atténuation et
l'adaptation la tenue graphique est
l'adaptation démographique vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic-là c'est
préconisation là pour certains c'est
absolument inaudible de poser la
question démographique on touche au cœur
du clivage qui est celui de la méthode
j'ose espérer je crois que sur ce
plateau on est assez convaincu de
l'urgence de la gravité de la
catastrophe d'accord la question c'est
celle de la méthode et en fait c'est
celle de la croissance ou de la
décroissance et moi j'assume ce clivage
non mais de la croissance démographique
ou de la décroissance démographique de
la croissance économique ou par je suis
de ceux qui pensent que politiquement
démocratiquement la seule voie qui peut
permettre l'adhésion de nos compatriotes
et l'adhésion des autres pays en
développement qui souhaitent la
croissance et une croissance verte et
bien c'est la seule voie qui peut
l'emporter il y a ceux qui pensent qu'on
doit passer par la décroissance et la
Société générale
ces deux croissances démographiques et
économiques sont différentes moi je suis
décroissantiste sur le plan
démographique mais croissance durable
sur le plan économique en tout cas il y
a des liens il y a des passerelles entre
vous deux hein ce soir on l'entend en
tout cas sur sur le diagnostic la
situation heureusement sur l'état de la
situation monsieur moi je trouve qu'on
exterminait en France en particulier
dans une incapacité à passer vers des
politiques publiques d'ampleur
d'adaptation et d'anticipation c'est à
dire que
on a vu on a vu au moment de la loi
pouvoir d'achat apparaître un terminal
méthanier et apparaître la réouverture
des centrales à charbon oui mais cela je
comprends bien mais le bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron
il faut quand même prendre la mesure de
ce qu'on doit faire et non on ne peut
plus faire ça aujourd'hui non on ne peut
pas avoir la main qui tremble au moment
des jets privés non on ne peut pas avoir
la main qui tremble au moment des
rénovations thermiques des bâtiments on
ne peut pas avoir la
il y a un grand texte sur les énergies
renouvelables qui arrivent à l'Assemblée
nationale vous l'aurez ce débat c'est
évident et j'espère d'ailleurs sur sur
ce plateau merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu sur le plateau dlcp Rémi lovelier
cette étude à la Fondation Jean Jaurès
dans la tête des échos anxieux une
génération face au dérèglement
climatique Antoine bueno l'effondrement
du monde n'aura probablement pas lieu
c'est-à-dire chez Flammarion merci à
vous on va accueillir à présent notre
grand témoin Elf Kerviel Cahuzac
Clearstream il a instruit les plus
grandes affaires politiques
co-financières 20 ans à explorer les
circuits opaques des paradis fiscaux il
y a énormément d'argent à nos portes
nous dit-il et personne ne fait rien il
nous l'explique dans son dernier livre
on va accueillir renovan redbeck qui
veut tout changer aux règles de
l'évasion fiscale juste après
l'invitation de Marion Becker
[Musique]
si on vous invite Renault van remake
c'est pour nous parler de votre pire
ennemi l'argent sale l'évasion fiscale
le milliard d'euros enfin des sommes
colossales qui échappent totalement à
l'impôt
quasiment dans la Punité dans votre
dernier ouvrage vous nous faites entrer
dans les coulisses des paradis fiscaux
ce monde offshore ou chemine cet argent
sale un monde opaque sur lequel vous
avez enquêté pendant plus de 20 ans
Renault van rumbeck vous êtes la figure
du magistrat libre et indépendant toute
votre carrière vous avez lutté contre la
corruption et pour l'indépendance de la
justice
que tout dossier doit être mené de la
même manière
quel que soit les personnes en cause
c'est à dire avec impartialité
sans aucun parti pris et en toute
indépendance vis-à-vis de qui que ce
soit c'était en 1992 vous êtes le
premier juge à perquisitionner le siège
d'un parti politique c'est l'affaire
urbain sur le financement du Parti
socialiste à faire elfe des frégats de
Taïwan clear stream vous avez instruit
elle les scandales les plus opaques de
la Cinquième République vous êtes l'une
des voies de l'Appel de Genève aux côtés
de magistrats européens anticorruption
vous demandez une harmonisation fiscale
et une levée du secret bancaire
20 ans plus tard dans votre livre vous
dévoilez les méandres des circuits
d'argent internationaux et les
mécanismes de la fraude fiscale et du
blanchiment d'argent cabinet de conseils
fiduciaires prête non vous mettez fin à
l'omerta de tout un système utilisé par
les grandes fortunes les dictateurs et
la criminalité pour échapper à l'impôt
ou blanchir l'argent sale en
investissant dans des luxueuses villas
de la Côte d'Azur ou dans des yachts
vous faites même une prescription au
service fiscaux mais ce que ce livre
démontre c'est aussi et surtout
l'incapacité des juges et des politiques
à démanteler ce système of Shore alors
on vous pose la question Renault von
rembeck ne croyez-vous pas que la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux est perdu
d'avance
bonsoir Renaud van rebec et merci
beaucoup d'être là bien c'est moi qui
vous remercie prenons la question qui
vous est adressée par Marion Becker on
connaît votre parcours et vous raconter
dans ces livres vraiment la difficulté
pour les juges qui tracent la fraude
fiscale d'accéder à des documents
secrets bancaires quand on voit la
facilité en un clic sur internet de
transférer de l'argent perdu d'avance ou
pas ce combat
alors je vais vous dire une chose je
n'aime pas perdre
très mauvais joueur donc c'est jamais
perdu d'avance il y a des fois on
n'arrive pas c'est vexant mais au moins
le maximum de ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour y arriver sans jamais baisser les
bras regardons les chiffres est-ce qu'on
va revenir dans le détail mais par
contre ici parce que la fraude fiscale
internationale ne s'est jamais aussi
bien portée entre 8000 et 36000
milliards de dollars selon les
estimations ça c'est quoi c'est le
montant de l'argent sale du blanchiment
de la corruption et de la fraude c'est
l'ensemble ce sont des économistes qui
ont avancé ces chiffres quand vous
avancez ces chiffres la fourchette est
extrêmement large parce que par
définition cet argent il est caché il
est caché dans les paradis fiscaux et
bien malin celui qui est capable de dire
exactement combien il y a l'argent cassé
puisqu'on ne le voit pas pour la France
ce serait 18 milliards d'euros par an de
pertes fiscales liées à la fraude alors
quelles sont les grandes places fortes
du secret bancaire dans le monde on
parle toujours de la du Luxembourg mais
vous vous insistez sur la vie vous
parlez beaucoup de Dubaï vous parlez de
Hong Kong
Dubaï est devenu véritablement une place
très prisée très recherchée par les
fraudeurs notamment les oligarques entre
autres parce que c'est une place d'abord
votre argent m'intéresse
je vais pas vous poser de questions sur
l'origine de l'argent et je pratiquement
pas vous taxer donc un syndrome de
fraudeur mais il y a les fraudeurs
fiscaux mais il y a aussi des des
trafiquants de drogue on a aujourd'hui
les oligarques qui sont poursuivis qui
savent que là ils peuvent placer leur
argent a priori parce que c'est jamais
complètement assuré en toute impunité
donc c'est un refuge et il fait office
de paradis fiscal j'allais dire même de
paradis bancaire parce que vous avez un
secret bancaire qui est très fort et un
paradis judiciaire parce que les juges
n'ont pas accès c'est très intéressant
c'est ça c'est consommé un peu dans la
peau d'un d'un juge du pôle financier
que vous avez été et qui est voilà
expert c'est un témoignage en trac de
fraude fiscal on découvre que la City de
Londres c'est le cœur du système
ça a été et ça l'est toujours plus ou
moins c'est pas le seul cœur du système
parce que ça c'est un système à
plusieurs à de multiples facettes mais
je peux vous dire que dans des dans des
affaires que j'ai vu qui m'étaient en
cause Londres et la Suisse la Suisse
faisait le travail dans les affaires de
correction et pas et pas l'Angleterre il
y a aucun scandale qui sort là-bas et la
City est une place forte avec un secret
très fort et c'est une part importante
du PIB de la Grande-Bretagne et il la
protège c'est pas aujourd'hui qui vont
lever le secret bancaire la lutte contre
le blanchiment la lutte contre les
paradis fiscaux c'est toujours brandi
comme une priorité dans toutes les
grandes réunions internationales les
chefs d'État et les dirigeants de la
planète on parle tout le temps mais vous
dans votre livre vous allez très loin
vous parler d'une duplicité du monde
occidental qui aurait atteint son
paroxysme oui parce que il y a des
bornes il y a des bonnes intentions il y
a des par exemple au CDE a beaucoup
œuvré pour avancer
il y a eu des listes qui ont été faits
des listes noires etc il y a eu des
tentatives mais le problème n'est pas
réglé le premier pas réglé parce que
vous avez toujours des sociétés grandes
des sociétés offshore des trusts des
cabinets de conseils qui vont pratiquer
l'évasion fiscale la fraude fiscale et
vous avez les mafiales trafiquants
drogues qui vont continuer à cacher leur
argent donc tant qu'on n'aura pas cassé
le système et c'est pas simple vous
aviez un débat tout à l'heure sur le sur
l'environnement que que j'ai suivi là
aussi on va faire on fait etc et on a
appris l'année dernière qui avait jamais
autant d'argent autant de CO2 d'hémiques
que l'an passé donc
il y a beaucoup de lanceurs d'alerte
maintenant il y a des consortiums de
journalistes qui travaillent
régulièrement il y a des scandales qui
sont révélés avec des personnalités des
noms qui sont donnés je pense au Panama
paper donc pendant la paper vous vous
dites ça c'est bien mais alors c'est
vraiment une toute petite partie
du phénomène oui parce que par exemple
les Panama papers c'est des milliers de
comptes mais c'est un cabinet alors un
gros cabinet Moissac Fonseca qui
fournissait clé en main des sociétés
panamiennes à ceux qui en voulaient pour
cacher leur argent mais derrière ça il y
en a beaucoup d'autres donc c'est un
travail extrêmement utile d'abord qui
montre parce que c'est récent les
derniers je crois que c'est 2021 j'ai
confond les Paradise et tout ça il y a
eu les bras voilà mais ça montre que le
phénomène persiste alors que depuis
2008-2009 on lui dit on met fin au
paradis fiscaux etc qui sont ces
officines dont vous parlez qui organise
la fraude précisément très concrètement
très concrètement ce sont des officines
qui sont basées à Singapour qui sont
basés maintenant à Dubaï qui sont au
Seychelles qui sont en Suisse qui sont
au Luxembourg et qui fournissent clé en
main une infrastructure de société
offshore qui va vous permettre de
masquer votre votre argent
parfois elle rapporte même de l'argent
aux États qui les abrite c'est ça l'idée
les pays en vivent les pays qui abritent
ces activités parce que c'est c'est
société qu'on appelle aussi des sociétés
fiduciaires il y a aussi de l'argent
propre il y a aussi un savoir-faire donc
le problème c'est que ils vont tout
gérer et en quelque sorte il faut il
faudrait que ces places et l'honnêteté
de dire on éradique tout ce qui est
argent sale c'est beaucoup d'argent qui
qui disparaîtra donc ils freinent les
quatre faits c'est un livre qui est
plein d'anecdotes aussi vous racontez
comment vous pouvez vous retrouver alors
que vous êtes déjà un très grand juge
d'instruction installées vous faire
intimider par le plus au plus haut
sommet de l'État que ce soit des
socialistes ou que ce soit la droite je
renvoie je renvoie au livre parce que
c'est passionnant Jacques Toubon Michel
Sarras en particulier qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on a l'impression quand même
que le seuil de tolérance est dépassé
aujourd'hui après le covid après
s'est rendu crènes la lutte contre les
avoir fiscaux des oligarques russes
quels levier d'action il faut que les
États qui sont spoliés je prends les
pays comme la France l'Allemagne etc ce
sont eux qui sont spolier parce que ce
sont des recettes considérables qui leur
échappent à un moment où ils en ont le
plus besoin en quelque sorte et les
hôpitaux il y a le dérèglement
climatique il va falloir investir des
sommes colossales on est en déficit il y
a des dettes très importantes je sais
pas où on va avec tout ça et à côté il y
a tout cet argent de la fraude fiscale
vous y croyez on a on a évoqué ça dans
la presse récemment ça serait pas mal
parce que
on ferait le point voilà on convoquerait
tout le monde on disait bon là où est-ce
qu'on en est comme on le fait en matière
d'environnement et on verrait bien où le
bas blesse et ce qu'il faut faire il est
pas normal qu'on puisse utiliser des
sociétés écran
qui servent juste de masque de cefshore
des trusts moi si j'achète une villa bon
évidemment elles vaudra pas 20 millions
ou 50 millions d'euros sauf si je
ressors mon compte de Liechtenstein ou
d’ailleurs bon mais trêve de
plaisanterie je l'achèterai à mon nom je
l'ai grave mes enfants pourquoi vous
voulez vous que je fasse appel à une
société pas laenne que un cabinet qui va
dire
il faut casser le système il faut casser
le système il faut exiger des pays où ça
se passe prendre par exemple les Panama
papers il y a un cabinet bon il est
montré du doigt le Panama va un petit
peu bouger contre ce cabinet mais il y
en a d'autres et qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
fait rien on les sanctionne pas alors
dernière question est-ce que vous
distinguez vraiment la fraude fiscale
est-ce qu'on appelle l'optimisation
fiscale je pense aux géant du numérique
qui en installant leur maison mère leur
siège dans des pays qui sont attrayantes
du point de vue fiscal essaie de payer
moins vous voyez une différence ou pour
vous c'est c'est aussi de la fraude pour
moi c'est aussi de la fraude à partir du
moment où vous avez à faire une armée de
de conseiller de montage qui sont
fictifs pour faire remonter des
bénéfices d'un pays à l'autre pour pas
payer d'impôts excusez moi si c'est pas
de la fraude qu'est-ce que c'est alors
on va dire évasion c'est légal parce
qu'on joue entre les les fiscalités
entre les différents pays mais c'est la
fiction qui me gêne et c'est la but
voilà et il n'est pas normal que les
plus grands groupes les Gafa etc arrive
par ce système à ne pas payer d'impôts
ou en payer beaucoup moins que ceux qui
sont les PME qui travaillent dans les
dans les dans l'Hexagone ou qui
travaillent en Allemagne ou ailleurs
merci beaucoup en tout cas dans la peau
d'un juge d'instruction c'est un
témoignage mais qui nous permet voilà
d'ouvrir les portes de ce monde
extrêmement opaque offshore dans les
coulisses des paradis fiscaux aux
éditions des liens qui libèrent je vous
de rester avec moi pour accueillir nos
affranchis Renault bec trois parties
prises ce soir on va accueillir Bertrand
Perrier pour commencer qui s'indigne ce
soir du refus du capitaine des Bleus
gauloris de porter un brassard
arc-en-ciel au
Qatar on va accueillir également Chloé
Ridel qui s'interroge sur un retour
possible ou pas des gilets jaunes juste
après la femme d'aristone à la pompe du
gouvernement et puis Palais Bourbon
Express ce soir avec Marco pommier sur
le premier feu vert des députés sur
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution nos affranchis les voici
bonsoir
ravi de vous retrouver on commence avec
vous Bertrand Bertrand Perrier vous
revenez sur les déclarations du
capitaine des Bleus gauloris ce soir qui
j'ai l'impression vous vous ont pas mal
agacé oui c'est vrai alors petit rappel
des épisodes précédents à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse à
Clairefontaine lundi dernier Hugo Lloris
est interrogé sur la possibilité pour
lui en tant que capitaine des Bleus de
porter ce fameux brassard qui est le
symbole de lutte contre les
discriminations et notamment des
discriminations dont sont victimes les
homosexuels c'est un brassard
arc-en-ciel et évidemment la question
est particulièrement polémique parce que
vous le savez
l'homosexualité et puni pénalement au
Qatar de peine de prison qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 7 ans et en réponse à
cette question Hugo Lloris dit que il ne
portera pas le brassard en question et
il dit lorsqu'on accueille des étrangers
en France on a souvent l'envie qu'il se
prête à nos règles et respecte notre
culture je peux être d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec leurs idées mais je dois
montrer du respect par rapport à cela
a suscité un tolé en tout cas beaucoup
de réactions oui beaucoup de réactions
ému un dîner et je crois qu'elles sont
au fond assez assez justifiées parce que
finalement si on en croit les propos du
goloris la pénalisation de
l'homosexualité serait une sorte
finalement de coutume locale qui de
respecter selon un peu l'adage à Rome
fait comme les Romains et donc
finalement il faudrait pour ne pas
détonner ne pas choquer dans un pays et
bien on respectait toutes les coutumes y
compris la pénalisation de
l'homosexualité et je crois qu'on ne
peut pas justement mettre sur le même
plan ce qui sont des habitudes de vie
auxquelles en effet on peut se plier
pour être dans la culture d'un pays pour
ne pas heurter et de l'autre côté des
libertés fondamentales avec lesquelles
on ne peut pas transiger donc je crois
que finalement la confusion du goloris
elle se fait entre ce qui est local et
ce qui est universel entre ce qui est
contingent et ce qui n'est pas
négociable et absolue donc voilà on va
en Espagne on peut négocier des horaires
de repas un peu plus tardif on peut
négocier sur des pratiques culturelles
mais véritablement la dépénalisation la
pénalisation de l'homosexualité ça n'est
pas ça c'est simple particularisme et on
ne peut pas respecter une telle
législation vous avez entendu le
président de la République il a dit
qu'il fallait pas politiser le sport
quand on interroge sur toute cette
affaire de boycott au cata est-ce que
c'est le rôle de prendre parti les
sportifs les footballeurs est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut leur demander des
positions politiques on peut leur
demander en réalité la Coupe du monde
fait que c'est une caisse de résonance
extraordinaire qui fait que par la
médiatisation dans l'objet
n'évitablement les acteurs que sont les
sportifs deviennent aussi des hommes
politiques ce qui suppose qu'ils
contrôlent leur propos comme le ferait
des hommes politiques on a su depuis que
la France donnerait l'équipe de France
donnerait des fonds à des associations
de protection des ONG et je me dis que
c'est heureux parce que là aussi dans la
protection des droits humains on
voudrait pouvoir dire we are the
champions
merci beaucoup Bertrand Perrier quel
parti pris vous vous êtes d'accord ça
vous choque au fond que le capitaine des
Bleus qui représente l'équipe tricolore
refuse de porter ça du golioris me
déçoivent parce que c'est un gardien
grand gardien qui a toujours montré du
fair-play sur le terrain et là
on se brouille pas quoi on reste
complètement extérieur mais au-delà de
ça regardez le nombre de morts qui a eu
les gens qui ont été exploités pour
cette coupe du monde je vais vous dire
une chose moi j'adore le football j'ai
joué un petit niveau je ne le regarderai
pas cette coupe du monde parce qu'il y a
trop de choses qui passent pas sans s'en
frotter le match de l'équipe de France
de l'équipe de France tout ça me j'ai un
espèce de rejet interne qui fait que je
et pourtant j'aime le foot mais là non
ça me j'ai mauvaise conscience attends
voilà c'est mon sentiment vous comprenez
ça maître Perrier oui nous nous
connaissons bien
en examen mes clients il y a 20 ans déjà
pour vous et votre talent en tant
qu'avocat
c'est le droit et le piano je ne sais
pas si vous avez pu en parler mais le
jugement
vous vouliez revenir ce soir sur un
anniversaire sur l'anniversaire des
quatre ans du gilet jaune parce qu'il y
a 4 ans exactement le 17 novembre 2018
avait lieu la première manifestation des
gilets jaunes et c'était des milliers de
gens qui sortaient qui enfilaient un
gilet fluorescent qu'ils étaient obligés
d'avoir dans leur voiture depuis
quelques années déjà pour s'installer
sur les ronds-points pour protester
contre la hausse des prix du carburant
liés à une nouvelle taxe carbone et puis
plus globalement pour le pouvoir d'achat
et cet élan spontanée des gilets jaunes
a inauguré le plus long mouvement social
en France depuis des décennies alors les
gilets jaunes c'était une révolte
fiscale c'était le symptôme d'un
aménagement du territoire qui oppose les
métropoles au périphéries et qui rend
les populations reléguées au périphérie
otage de leur voiture et donc de la
hausse des prix du carburant c'était
aussi l'éruption sur la scène politique
des marginalisés Christophe Guigui
dirait de la France périphérique celle
qu'on ne voit nulle part celle qui est
absente des médias et des réseaux de
pouvoir alors est-ce qu'on a entendu le
message des gilets jaunes est-ce qu'on a
tiré les leçons selon vous de cette
question que je voudrais on se pose et
pour être direct j'y répondrai par un
nom franc ou alors on l'a entendu mais
les actes ne suivent pas prenons les
thèmes un par un est-ce que nous avons
réduit la dépendance de la voiture des
populations qui vivent dans entre
guillemets la France périphérique non
cette dépendance elle est toujours aussi
forte vous me direz des choses aussi
lourdes que l'aménagement du territoire
ne peuvent pas changer en 4 ans mais
tout de même le gouvernement continue
aujourd'hui de faire des chèques pour
faire baisser artificiellement les prix
du carburant vous avez 10 millions de
Français qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté le train n'est toujours pas
assez développé ni le vélo d'ailleurs
deuxième thème est-ce que on a amélioré
le pouvoir d'achat des des plus modestes
guère en Ukraine qui a été ce qu'on a
amélioré la répartition de la richesse
non l'inflation des prix de l'énergie
des produits alimentaires galopent c'est
vrai en partie à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine mais le SMIC n'a pas été
augmenté au même niveau que l'inflation
de même que les salaires de façon
générale non plus et sur la répartition
des richesses on a eu un débat récemment
avec la publication du salaire de
Patrick puyanné PDG total et ses 6
millions d'euros annuel qui a remis la
lumière sur la question des écarts de
salaire et du partage de la richesse
dans notre pays qui reste extrêmement
inégal parce que si vous trouvez que
pouyanais qui aime trop d'argent ou ce
serait ravi d'apprendre qu'il gagne en
fait 40 % de moins que la moyenne des
patrons du CAC 40 est-ce que gagne c'est
340 fois le SMIC en France le ratio
entre le salaire des grands patrons et
celui d'un salarié le plus modeste était
de 1 à 25 dans les années 80 et
aujourd'hui de 1 à 400 on voit bien la
question de la justice sociale
il y avait aussi une demande de
représentation effectivement est-ce que
ceux qui
vivent dans de qui sont des employés des
ouvriers sont aujourd'hui mieux
représentés dans le débat public et dans
les réseaux de son pouvoir là aussi on
voit que la sous-représentation des
ouvriers et des employés ici à
l'Assemblée nationale demeure puisque
les ouvriers les employés totalisent
respectivement 0,9% et 4,5% de
l'ensemble des députés alors qu'il
représente 16% de la population
française et c'est d'ailleurs au sein du
groupe du Rassemblement national qui
sont les plus nombreux et enfin dernier
thème des gilets jaunes on peut pas
parler des gilets jaunes sans parler de
ça le maintien de l'ordre les violences
policières
les gilets jaunes avaient donné lieu à
très nombreuses personnes et borniers
aux mains arrachées blessées par des
tirs de lanceur de balle de défense LBD
et là on n'a pas l'impression que la
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
française est évoluée depuis 4 ans alors
même que à l'époque le Défenseur des
droits Jack Toubon avait demandé à ce
qu'on interdise l'utilisation des LBD et
on le voit récemment à la répression qui
a été celle de la manifestation contre
les méga bassines à Sainte Soline que la
doctrine de maintien de langue française
n'est pas près d'évoluer alors qu'elle
concentre à juste titre les critiques
donc je pose une question pour finir
combien d'autres anniversaires nous
faudra-t-il pour enfin entendre le
message qu'il faut suivre des gilets
jaunes et ben voilà on a rien compris
selon que Ridel partager le constat ce
qui est étonnant pour rejoindre le sujet
qui était abordé avant c'est que
Monsieur pouillané on parle de 6
millions d'euros par an
si je le compare au salaire de joueur de
foot connus eux gagnent beaucoup plus et
ça choque personne bon donc quand on
parle d'inégalités
ce soir vous vous arrêtez sur cette
proposition de loi pour inscrire le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution oui Myriam souvenez-vous en
juin dernier la Cour suprême américaine
remettait en cause le droit de le droit
à l'avortement décision qui a créé un
électrochoc juste en Europe et ici en
France des députés veulent éviter un tel
scénario c'est le cas du groupe
renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle mais aussi de la France
insoumise inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans
la Constitution permettrait que ce droit
ne soit pas abrogé par une simple loi
écouter Aurore berger c'est elle qui a
déposé la proposition de loi pour le
groupe Renaissance
il me semble pour ma part que le
contexte national et surtout
international fait planer une menace de
plus en plus inquiétante sur le droit à
l'avortement et exige cette protection
supplémentaire voilà la proposition de
loi d'Aurore berger qui a été adoptée en
commission des lois elle sera débattue
dans l'hémicycle le 28 novembre prochain
les républicains et le rassemblement
national y sont opposés pour eux c'est
pas utile le droit à l'avortement n'est
pas menacé en France la gauche en
revoche en revanche votera le texte de
la majorité présidentielle et dès jeudi
prochain le 24 novembre elle est députés
devront aussi se prononcer sur la
proposition de loi de la France
insoumise qui vise le même objectif
alors là il y a deux propositions de loi
moi je comprends pas pourquoi on en fait
pas qu'une seule on va tout expliquer
parce qu'en vérité la proposition de loi
portait par Mathilde panneaux présidente
du groupe la France insoumise est un peu
différente de celle du camp présidentiel
écouter Daniel Simonet elle nous
explique
la différence entre les deux textes
c'est que le nôtre prévoit d'inscrire
dans la Constitution et le droit
d'avortement et le droit à la
contraception voilà Myriam pour la
différence la nuit pèse veut aussi
constitutionnalisée le droit à la
contraception et c'est assez rare pour
le souligner mais la majorité
présidentielle votera le texte des
insoumis dans l'hémicycle la semaine
prochaine alors alliance de circonstance
alliance baroque ou pas dans la majorité
de conviction aussi aussi dans la
majorité on assume l'enjeu de
l'avortement est trop important
sur cet enjeu là il y a aucune
difficulté et de vous voyez bien qu'elle
Assemblée nationale il y a pas que LFI
qui est derrière cette proposition de
loi il y a aussi nos collègues
socialistes et ELV on fait aussi de la
diplomatie quand on voit une loi à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de la
diplomatie féministe on envoie un signal
aux autres pays du monde
alors avec quelle chance d'aboutir
est-ce que c'est fait ce droit va être
inscrit ou pas le chemin reste long
Myriam la deuxième étape c'est le Sénat
il faudrait que les sénateurs votent au
moins l'une des deux propositions de loi
de l'Assemblée sauf que mi-octobre la
chambre haute a rejeté un texte qui
allait dans ce sens alors ici à
l'Assemblée les députés de la majorité
sont persuadés que leur texte a plus de
chance de passer au Sénat que celui des
insoumis tout simplement parce que leur
texte propose la constitutionnalisation
d'Olivier pas de la contraception enfin
dernière étape Myriam mais pas des
moindres si le Sénat adopte la
proposition de loi
IVG dans les mêmes termes que
l'assemblée elle devra ensuite être
adoptée par référendum il y a encore un
petit chemin c'est ça à faire cohéridel
vous seriez favorable il faut
sanctuariser ce droit dans notre
relation doit suprême quand on voit ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis ça fait
froid dans le dos et je suis favorable
la question de l'avortement soit posée
chez nous dans une enceinte politique et
que aux États-Unis elle soit posée dans
une enceinte judiciaire
merci à tous les affranchis merci
infiniment merci beaucoup
de LCP offshore dans les coulisses des
paradis fiscaux c'était aux éditions des
liens qui libèrent très belle soirée
documentaire et à demain
[Musique]